.
THE ROLE IS TO REGARD ON LEGAL
STRATEGY.
WE LEARNED OF PAT CIPOLLONE AND
ANOTHER FAMOUS CASE, THEY CAN
GET DRAWN INTO SO MUCH MORE.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL JOHN
DEAN APPEARS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE AND GIFTS EXPLOSIVE
TESTIMONY FOR THE PLANNING OF
THE BREAK-IN, COVERUP AND
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY UNDERTAKEN BY
HIS FORMER BOSS PRESIDENT
RICHARD NIXON AND HIS AIDES.
>> I BEGAN TELLING THE
PRESIDENT, THERE WAS A CANCER
GROWING ON THE PRESIDENCY.
>> Reporter: DEAN WAS
IMPLICATEING NIXON AND OTHER
OFFICIALS AND HIMSELF IN THE
WATERGATE SCANDAL, A CRUCIAL
MOMENT IN THE DEMISE OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
DEAN LATER PLED GUILTY TO
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE CHARGES
AND SERVED PRISON TIME.
>> HE'S A HERO FOR GONE AND
SAVED THE DEMOCRACY THAT WAS
UNDER THREAT DURING THE
WATERGATE.
>> Reporter: CONTRAST JOHN DEAN
WITH PAT CIPOLLONE, CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON, A FORMER AIDE TO
MARK MEADOWS TESTIFIED THAT
CIPOLLONE WAS IN CLOSE TOUCH
WITH HER JANUARY 6th AND
DESPERATELY TRYING TO KEEP THE
THEN PRESIDENT FROM GOING UP TO
CAPITOL HILL WITH THE RIOTERS.
>> MR. CIPOLLONE SAID SOMETHING
TO THE EFFECT OF, PLEASE MAKE
SURE HE DOESN'T GO UP TO THE
CAPITOL, CASSIDY.
KEEP IN TRUMP WITH ME.
WE WILL GET CHARGED WITH EVERY
CRIME IMAGINABLE IF YOU MAKE
THAT MOVE HAPPENED.
>> Reporter: SHE SAID CIPOLLONE
WAS CONCERNED HE COULD BE
ACCUSED OF OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE.
HUTCHINSON SAID CIPOLLONE ADDED
OTHER DIRE WARNINGS.
>> PAT SAID SOMETHING CLEARLY
SAID, THIS TO MARK, SOMETHING TO
THE EFFECT OF, MARK, SOMETHING
NEEDS TO BE DONE OR PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO DIE AND BLOOD IS GOING
TO BE ON YOUR F'ING HANDS.
>> Reporter: REPORTEDLY,
CIPOLLONE PUSHED BACK ON PLANS
BY TRUMP TO USE THE POWER OF THE
PRESIDENCY TO OVERTURN THE 2020
ELECTION RESULTS.
UNLIKE JOHN DEAN, WE HAVE NOT
HEARD FROM PAT CIPOLLONE.
HE IS APPEARED WITH A CLOSED
DOOR AND NOT AGREED TO TESTIFY
PUBLICLY, DRAWING CRITICISM FROM
THE PANEL'S VICE CHAIR.
>> WE THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE TO HEAR FROM
MR. CIPOLLONE, PERSONALLY.
>> Reporter: THE ANALYSTS SAY
CIPOLLONE, SO FAR, HASN'T GONE
OUT ON A LIMB LIKE DEAN DID.
THEY BELIEVE HE SHOULD HAVE
CONTACTED OTHER CABINET MEMBERS
ABOUT TRUMP'S BEHAVIOR OR SHOULD
HAVE RESIGNED.
>> Y